my name is sean sharon i'm a software
engineer at wolfram research
and i'm presenting here with um robert
collier i'm also a software engineer
here at wolfram research and
let's dive right in so
yeah you've already seen the abstract we
want to talk today about some
new features as well as some cool
applications that
i think that people are going to be
excited about with um the updates coming
to import and export
so just to give a quick summary of what
we're going to talk about we have some
brand new formats
z standard which is the new compression
algorithm developed by facebook
onyx export we had import before and now
you're able to take your
neural net objects and export those to
onyx
we have pem import for working with
different
cryptography objects and a number of
updated formats
in particular there's a huge update to
pdf coming in the next version
that completely overhauls import we've
obsoleted ag vorbis m4a
and swf ag vorbis and m4a are still
available under the new formats
mp4 and og there are some updates to
video formats generally package was
renamed to wl
and dataset export now works in xlsx
there's some dicom updates some image
updates
and then we're going to talk about some
other things that my team has been
working on specifically related to
url support and import related functions
as well as
some updates to file format let's jump
right into z standard
so with z standard
the the big push to get this the system
is that
it has notably better compression and
notably
faster compression times so if we just
grab here the declaration of
independence and repeated about 10 000
time that gives us a good example for
something that's easily compressible
the original size of this file was 90
megabytes
and after a quick export we were able to
get that all the way down to
12 kilobytes that's a tremendous
improvement
and you'll even notice that this works
both with export
and create archive
the cool thing about z standard is the
fast timing and
the really good compression ratios
you'll notice that it has a smaller file
size than gzip
in less time
onyx export has been added oh sorry i
forgot to say one thing about z
standard z standard is also hooked up
under the hood
you may have noticed that when you
import things that are gzip compressed
it kind of takes care of that auto
magically
and then gets to the content underneath
you'll see the same thing with z
standard it's hooked up across the
system the same way that gzip and bzip2
are
so jumping into just a simple onyx
import we can grab a net graph
or even just a specific layer of a graph
from an onyx file
so say that you have some net graph that
you generate here
and you want to preserve that so that
you can use it in future sessions
onyx is a great format for exporting
this data
here you can see that we exported a
graph as well as a single layer
you can also control metadata in the
audix file using options to export
and as you can see this is a fairly
faithful
reproduction of the net graph that we
originally put in
when we import it from that file
pem import is another new format
pem files look like this they have some
comments saying which
chunk of data you're about to receive
and then just some data
this is a private key pem files contain
things like private keys public keys
and security certificates
so we have a private key here
and we have a public key
and with that we're able to generate a
digital signature from the private key
that anybody with the public key can
verify
the biggest thing that i want to talk
about today is the
many enhancements to pdf import so one
thing i have to note
unfortunately i missed the build by just
one day with the packet for pdf tools
if you're following along and the
notebook is already uploaded on pathable
you're going to have to run this to fix
the conference builds of course
everything will work out of the box once
12 2 is released
let's go ahead and download a couple of
pdf files that i found online
yes pem does support multiple keys
within the same file
okay so if we just take a look at the
elements list this has grown quite a bit
there are several new elements ranging
from metadata
to annotation type data like highlighted
text
and urls so you can extract more data
from the pdfs themselves
in addition to a complete overhaul on
getting back images and also getting
back plain text
so let's just start by mentioning that
the default element for
import a pdf has changed the default
element is now
page images and what page images gives
you is
images of each page these are no longer
graphics objects
the huge upside to this is that these
images are absolutely faithful and
robust
renders of these images so if you really
want to get an
accurate depiction of what the page
looks like this is going to work
perfectly for you now
you can grab a single page efficiently
from a pdf document
and you can control its image resolution
this is particularly important if you've
seen my previous talks
for doing some kind of ocr if you have a
really high resolution
you're going to get much more faithful
recognition
when using functions like text recognize
you can also see that it's quite zippy
we can get the
timing right here and it's very quick
to get all of the plain text from this
file
you can grab the plain text for just a
particular page
and again that's efficient you can even
get formatted texts
that take styling elements directly from
the document and applies them
to the page
you can get hyperlinks now that actually
come back as hyperlinks that you can see
the display text in addition to the link
underneath
and we have url support so if you just
want the urls you don't care about these
things coming back as hyperlinks you can
get those directly too
embedded images is going to give you
back an association of the page number
that embedded images were found
on and a list of the embedded images on
that page
we also have strong metadata support and
pdf documents so if you're trying to do
some analysis on
where these pdfs are coming from you can
look at things like the creator
here's where we're getting into some
even cooler new stuff
now usually with a table of contents if
you opening it in a pdf viewer
you just want to get some idea of which
page do i go to
to see what's you know this section
and what i wanted to do was create
something that took that to another
level and gave you something that was
even more computable
so this returns an actual graph here and
this graph
has nodes that depend on the parent that
the section is a part of
what what is neat about this is you can
actually do graph computations
using the object that you get back from
contents graph so you can see that
there's associations that give them name
and ids
which is essential because the names can
be duplicate and
gives you the structure the kinds of
things that you could do with that are
go through and get the names or
try to figure out some kind of analysis
of the depth from
the root of the document so this bit of
code here
grabs the graph distance of
each vertex in the graph
back to the first vertex in the graph
annotation also has rich support now so
let's grab
this pdf document and
let's go ahead and start highlighting
some text because we want to go through
and get very specific pieces of
information out later
i can highlight that and let's just save
the document
well let's draw something on it too how
about a nice
big smiley face at the top of the
document
when so we have a new element called
highlighted text that's just going to
give you
the specific chunks of text that
are on each page so it'll tell you the
page number that i found highlighted
text and what the text was
page images by default is going to
render all of these things
but you have control over rendered
elements and pdf with the rendered
elements option
and for my favorite new feature we have
forms
so here is the i9 form straight from the
irs
this is uh for those who aren't in the
states this is a document used by the
irs to determine that you are an
eligible employee in the united states
um if we just take a look at the form
field rules
we have the names of the form fields so
these are set when you create the form
document
and the values of them right now they're
all blank you can see that it's just a
bunch of empty strings
let's open this file that i just
downloaded
and go in and put in some information so
let's give it my last name
my first name and how about a state i'm
from minnesota so let's do that
great we can save this
and take a look at the fields that we've
just filled in so now i'm just taking
the form field rules
on page four and grabbing any string
that actually has some data in it so you
can see
that i just saved the document and now
we can extract the
values as well as the names of the form
fields
and you can look up by their names than
the values that you want to use in your
analysis i wanted to take this one step
further because the first thing that i
thought of when i was developing this is
how easy it would be to automate getting
pdf documents that you distribute and
doing some kind of analysis
on the responses that you get in those
form fields
so let's just start
with with an idea we want to make a
geographics that drops a pin
on the state of everybody who has
submitted the form
and there we are so it drops a pin on
minnesota and notice how simple this
code is all we have to do is use
interpreter
to identify what these strings are
so we need somewhere to accumulate all
the submissions from people
so we'll make a data bin for that right
now the data bin is empty
but if we were to just make a simple web
request we can drop some data into our
data bin
maybe the state wisconsin now you'll
notice that in our data bin we have
wisconsin
i can make a cloud object called data
map
and so can you fill the forms
programmatically and save the pdf
again you can't do that in mathematica
just yet
so if you want to fill out forms you're
going to need another editor for that
if anybody wants to follow along i just
url shortened this um
cloud object link here and we're going
to see that
we can actually
now just beef this code up a little bit
to extract the values from
bin rather than um
you know just hard coding in the value
minnesota before so let's deploy this
thing
we're going to take our geographics
deploy it as an exported png
and we're going to tell it to update
this cloud object every three seconds
let's take a look at what we get
all right we have an image it's dropped
the point anybody can access this cloud
object now
let's go ahead and drop another piece of
data in there just arizona
i realize that we haven't done the pdf
part yet but we'll get there
all right so our bin has arizona and
wisconsin if we take a look at this oh
look arizona's already populated
great so what i really wanted to show
here
was this example down here and i'll just
i'll run it and show you what it looks
like
upload a pdf file to create a form page
where people can go and submit the
results is
just yet again one line of code that
in here contains the
importer to extract data from a
particular field
and then pass that in as data since we
can't do that the only reason we can't
do that right now is because
well the cloud isn't running 12.2 and
this is going to be deployed as an api
function
so what i'm going to do instead to show
you how this works
is come here and instead of uploading a
pdf
file i'm just going to type in the name
of state so let's try texas
okay it gets added let's see if it shows
up on our data bin
great there it is so what i'm trying to
show is that you can
upload a pdf document immediately get
the
values that were filled in from your
users and do some kind of analysis and
publish that to a cloud api in just five
lines of code
one other example i want to show from
pdf this was already shown in steven's
keynote
just in the past week michael trott has
put together this wonderful example
showing
a list of sightings of mathematica being
used in the wild
in various scientific papers and using
the new importer he was able to get all
this information
and you can click on these things and
dive into what those papers
talk about
so video codecs we've improved the
selection of best available encoders
so it should work out of the box
whatever platform you're on and whether
or not you have system fmpeg
we have also wanted to emphasize that if
you
go to the tutorial importing and
exporting video
you can actually download xfmpeg and
hook it up to our system so that you can
use the full range of codecs
that we aren't able to ship due to
various patents
so obsolete formats are ag vorbis m4a
and swf swf just doesn't exist in the
wild anymore
ag verbus and m4a are being superseded
by their video counterparts so
you'll notice that if you call file
format on an m4a you get mp4 these
actually get imported as audio objects
not video objects like mp4s do
and export is significantly faster it
took 28 seconds because i had to do some
transcoding before
if you're exporting a video now and it's
able to
do so without making a copy or sorry
without transcoding and instead using a
copy encoder it's significantly faster
just a couple of small updates packages
renamed to wl
these operate the exact same package
still works if you have that in your
code
but we wanted to modernize it to go with
our branding
dataset export works in xlsx
as you can see i just opened it in excel
and there's the data from my export
and i'm going to hand it off here
to robert let me just quickly answer
this question can you create a form from
a scanned pdf
by assuming the square white boxes are
checked boxes
and lines that extend along text
baselines or fillable text fields
well you wouldn't sorry
are you saying that you had some paper
document that you scanned because
obviously then there's not going to be
form fields in there
if there's form fields the check boxes
come in as actual binary or
come in as booleans if it's a paper
document then you're looking at doing a
bunch of ocr and image recognition
okay on to robert
okay just let me share
i can stop there we go yeah thank you
we'll just share it all and hope for the
best
okay um previously we had
uh dicom import we've added
my apologies let's push that up we now
have
a exporter added
and and we can do the
usual things take an image
export it create an image list because
dicom
is in a format that can have image lists
um also like normal
we can we have named rules or
for image list and image
and there are others there's graphics so
you can
uh graphics to graphics list so you can
export
um cells or
other other things but
we don't need that for an example here
probably one of the more
interesting examples is the export event
meta information
and this is fairly broad
we can specify quite a few things there
are
a number of keys that are by default
um but
as you can see you know nate you know
these courses these are written as
we've entered them including this is a
quantity
let's deal with the zoom screen
okay um the more extensive updates
though
are into sort of miscellaneous updates
involving
the uh the meta information data
we've consolidated everything under one
previously we had exif and xmp
and for example iptc they're still
queryable individually um
but they're also queryable now
completely under meta information
some of our examples already have them
and
we have extensive uh information
available from
the more more extensive thing is they've
also been restructured to some extent
um these used to be
at like document id used to be at the
top level
a few others they've been actually been
organized under the uh
different schemas so that
they're while they're more in
their into the associations a little bit
deeper they're just organized better
same with uh just plain x and p
um although plain xmp
actually does formatting as opposed to
the raw
which just gives you the raw
uninterpreted dates and things like that
um
[Music]
this is i don't this
used to be along the lines of where were
for this particular file there were 50
about 50 uh uh
exif items that we were available we've
added
support for numerous others for example
rawhide ball maximal width um
more interestingly though we now
put the push the image resolution into
the xf data
so we have width resolution
resolution unit
we even add what we hope are reasonable
defaults
um in twelve one we added an importer
for
hey for hake depending on which format
um this is only on
out of the box on mac due to patents but
you can get download stuff for windows
um sorry linux at the moment you know
there isn't available
um in this case i don't have the uh
i only have the system ffmpeg up so
forget
a complete um
but some interesting examples like on
mac os
x we have a depth image
which this is a effectively a height map
everything that's dark is close the
brighter pixels represent
distances that are farther away and this
gives us
actually a good example so we have our
image when we mouse over we can blur
anything that is far away
which sort of imp i have
i have kids coming in in the background
so it might get a little noisy my
apologies
um and
we now had to active for it
um as extensive as our other support
i keep
okay more interesting though
we've added url support through a lot of
our functionality
file format for example can go out
and grab this it doesn't have a file
name associated with it
but from the mime type we're able to
determine that it's json data
similarly for import because we can
tell from the mind type that is json we
know how to import it
for me the most interesting example
though is is the create archive one
where we can include files that are
remote in addition to our local ones
and create an archive
and from there or
extract one from over the web
so let's be that we've at um previously
there were three functions that were in
import export um context
we've moved them to system and they're
there are
these um file format queue stream format
queue in binary format
they let allow you to ask the question
is this file of a particular type
and we accept both the um
an alternatives format or a list
previously these uh would not go
looking inside of a gzip but now they do
the same with street format q and byte
array format queue
as part of bringing these into system we
also did a little bit more work
in
the file format in general uh for now
and we added a second argument because
there were a lot of cases where we saw
this type of code
when you know you want to find out what
type of file it is and you have a
limited list
that you can work with and
this is often this isn't a terribly
expensive operation
but if you do it a lot you might as well
save what time you can
and this
we cut off all the you know cut out all
the time required to open and close the
file read in the data
and we get to do it at once if you have
nothing
if you place um if your file
doesn't correspond to any uh format in
your list we will return
them um as part of this
oops we added
a string format binary format
and also now have a common
implementation
uh with file format so with things like
a gzip
wrapped gif it can detect it where
previously
it couldn't look inside at all the same
is true
with byte array
lastly we have this are some several
options
uh max items is the only one on this
list that is documented
in general so the rest could potentially
go away
but the idea is sometimes they you have
more than one item
or the one format that it matches so you
might want to see which ones they match
um if you have a case where it's limited
now this now if you note it since it
didn't match two
it only returned the one
a2 is equivalent in this case is
equivalent to an up to two
similar the if you have no matches
it will return an m2 list um
sometimes uh there are cases we've found
where
decoding is something we don't want
so we've added
an option that if you just want to look
at the top
now note this would go through for if
this is just a gif this would also pick
it up but
it won't look inside a gzip or a bzip
a more interesting case is when you're
talking about
like something we don't have a strong
test for like json
um when you just have a screen of it
it can't pick it up correctly because it
doesn't have we don't have enough
information
there's a lot of for json most of the
information we have is
in the file name itself for instance
this one
actually looks like a csv file for all
intents and purposes
um but we've added an option where you
can add
a file name and
it can then pick it up now this doesn't
do away with the other tests for
instance if you were to suggest it was a
jpeg
but it is really png the png wins
because of the magic number tabs
that we have available similarly with
mime type
we can do it with mime types although
these fall very at least fall towards
the end
these are essentially if we have um
no data at all left so we can use the
mime type
but likewise a png
would outweigh the uh the mime type
so i that is
it for me i think we're close to
actually being
done yeah it looks like we had pretty
good time there
yes we did uh we so i know that the
pathable room is going to be closed in
10 minutes if people want to stick
around and ask us questions for 10
minutes we'll be here
you can also find us again at the booth
tomorrow at 12 30 pm central time you
can find that on your schedule
if you'd like to join and talk to us
we'll have a half hour there
um otherwise you can also click on our
names in
the talk and feel free to schedule a
meeting with us or send us a message if
you have questions about any of these
things that you don't necessarily want
to bring to
right now or office hours
does anybody have any questions
you could raise your hand or put it in
chat
otherwise are there you know any formats
that people are particularly excited to
see that we are updating are there
formats
that users want um
want us to start getting to looks like
we're going to get a question about zstd
here
i don't think url fetch decodes z
standard automatically
that
that's more in the curl level of stuff
so import will decode zstd automatically
url fetch probably won't yeah yeah i
know that it does for gzip in fact
in order to do all this url
modernization stuff i actually had to
ask fahim to
give me a way to disable that gzip stuff
so that i could get the raw contents
so zstd probably not if if it can be
supported it's something that's
supported through curl
so that would be a separate mechanism
okay we have another question here in
the zoom chat
asking about tech import
um is there a more specific question
and perhaps i can give you know somewhat
of an overview of where we're at with
tech so we have some basic tech
import capabilities
there have been some projects working on
improving tech a bit in the company
that haven't quite come to fruition yet
we definitely have it on our list of
things that we want to provide better
support for
and you know undoubtedly at some point
in the future we'll improve on that
all right well looks like i'm watching
the attendees list drop pretty quickly
so
thank you everybody for coming and you
know where to find us